Two Coins Are Tossed Together What is the
Probability of Getting Heads on One and Tails on
the Other Heads on One and Tails on the Other Let's
Recollect What We Did in the
Previous Videos How Many Different
Possibilities Exist When Two Coins Are
Tossed Heads on One End  Head on the other Head and
tail Tail and head tails on both four
possibilities In all in the question we've been asking the
probability of getting a head
on one and a tail on the other there are two ways in which this
can happen head and tail  Is one
and tail and head is the other so out of four
possibilities we have two possibilities which satisfy
the condition so we can write the
probability of getting a head and a tail
as
2/4 which equals half does not even equal head on one and
tail  On the other means only this
possibility it has been specified which
coin gets a head and which one gets a
tail so we also
consider this possibility let me modify the question a
bit what is the probability of getting at least
one head when two coins are tossed  Similarly we have to look at
outcomes where we get at least
one head it means either one head or two
heads so the possibilities are head and head head and tail and tail
and head these are the
three ways in which we can get at least one
Head in the fourth possibility there is no head
so we can write the probability of getting at least
one head as
3/4 three ways out of a possible for there is
another way to get the
answer probability of getting at least one
head can also be  Written as one minus
probability of getting no heads at all one includes all the
possibilities and you can say maximum probability and we are just
removing the unwanted one which is why we have
the minus sign tail and tail is the only
case where we don't get  A head so it can be
written as 1 - 1/4 that equals
3/4 the answer remains the same just that we
derive the answer a bit differently in this
case this concept where we remove the unwanted
ones from the sample set is super important
And comes in handy when we have many
[music]
possibilities